あの第一講義では まあほとんど厳密に必要なポイントをまとめたと思いますけど
まあそれからまあほんのちょっとの説明だと思います
で この前の話で一応言ったのは
この本音と建前っていうのは 2つあるのは当たり前で
それがすごいノーマルな状態で
もしそこがなくなっちゃうとかなり危ないっていうことでね
しかし 人間っていうのは
この本音をいじめていると
本音がすごくかっこ悪い
悪いと思ってるんですね
だから本音というのは人に見せないものだから
それがかっこ悪いと思って
これ本音をいじめているんですね
だからこの 本音をいじめることで
我々は色々困ったりすることはたくさん出てくる
で 正直な人って何なのかというテーマもありましたし
それから本音と建前の関係ということで話してやったんです
だから今日は まあ顔がいくつあるのかということで How
many faces do you have? というタイトルで
そこでこのこちらにあるサブタイトルではなくて Inventory
control of your facesという私は副題を入れたんです
いわゆる顔の在庫管理なんです
たくさん顔があると人間に
たくさんあるんだったら
やっぱり在庫管理は必要なんです
それはで あの ただ英語で How many faces do you have? と聞いたっても
誰でも簡単にワンと答えるでしょうね
もう一つ 私は考えた英語の質問があって Who
are you? という質問がありますね Who
are you? Who are you? ということは
あなたは誰ですか？という日本語の意味ですけど
では Who are you? と聞かれたらどう答えますかね
普通は名前を言います
一番普通は名前を言うんですね
初めて会った人だったらね Who
are you? と言えばね
でもそれ決まってる答えではありません
例えば 私たちは突然どこかの学校に行く
行ったらそこら辺がある
まあ女性の方がウロウロしている
で まあ服装もそんなにもまとめていないし
それで私たちはもしかすると Who are you? と聞いたら I am a teacher of the school. と答える可能性ありますよ
名前ではなくて だから必ずしも名前というわけじゃない
それはすっごい一般的な言葉なんです
名前を言うの 大体名前を聞きたい場合は Who are you? とは聞かないんです
そこで あまり英語ばっかり言って申し訳ないんですけど
もう一つ英語の言葉があります What
are you? What are you? という質問もあります
その場合は答え決まってます
何ですか その場合 職業なんです
で これでまあそれはまあ一般的な社会です
しかし もっと哲学的に考えると Who
are you? と質問されちゃうと答えられないと思いますよ
もし真面目に答えようと思ったら
バカもんで 私みたいに真面目に答えようと思ったら答えられないと思いますよ
いい加減でだったら答えられます
もう何か言えばいいんだからね
いい加減な場合は  本当に真剣
真面目に Who are you? ということに答えることになると
結構難しいと思います
それはこの複数の顔という問題なんですね
で 家に行って まあ家にまあお子さんがいて
まあといった女性がいると
で それで Who are you? と言ったら I
am the mother of the house. という可能性もあるし
I am the housewife. という可能性もあるし mother
という言葉と housewife という言葉の場合はかなり違うんですよ
本人が自分の一つの側面を言うだけなんです
ではあの 続いていきます
本当に我々はこの複数の顔をお持ちでしょうかと
で 顔とは社会に対して示す自分の性格なんです
そうなると顔を一つしかないはずです
自分の顔っていうのは
まあどうせこの肉体的な顔でないことはわかりますでしょうし
だから我々は社会に対して社会に見せる性格なんですね
例えば 私たちは人に「あんたまだ子供ですね」と言うと
それがその人がこの生年月日計算してみれば
子供の 18歳以下で子供の保護に入るという意味ではありませんね
その場合は 社会に見せた顔から性格から見ると未熟で大人気ない
だから「あんたまだ子供ですね」と言うんです
だからその人は社会に対して子供の顔を見せちゃったんです
そこで私が社会に見せる顔であるならば
社会に見せる性格であるならば
一つしかないはずなんですけど
そうでもない 事実はいかがでしょうかということで
そうでもないんです で
次に考えてみましょう
問題はこの複数の社会があるんですよ
社会が 1個でないということは今日勉強してほしい
今日のポイントはそれなんです
社会に見せる顔といったら
社会が 1個だったら顔一つしかない
性格一つしかない 問題は社会が 1個じゃないんですよ
困ったことに 観念的には社会は一つです
頭の中だけだったら しかし実際は社会に出会うことは
起こらない 起こる 何でしたっけ
起こらない出来事です
社会に出会うっていうことは
我々の人生では起こらないんですよ
だからちょっとおかしいんですよ
皆様 社会人でしょうに
社会にあったことはないと言っちゃうとおかしいんじゃないんですかね
だから今日そのポイントを説明したいと思います
我々は結局は社会にあったことはない
社会っていうのは観念的なものなんです
具体的にあるものじゃないんです
だから観念的なものだったら
どうやって出会いますかね
我々はある特定の社会にのみ出会うのです
社会だと一般的に言う社会には会う機会がないということで
同じことを繰り返してますけど
我々は実際に出会っているのは特定の社会なんであって
社会という一般的な この本やら色々なところに出てくるこの観念的な社会ではありません
特定の社会 で 次に行きます
で 複数の世界があるっていうことは
そんなに難しくないんで
今日言ってることは 個人の人生を具体的に見てみましょう
それでこのブッダのこの教えを理解するために
仏教っていうのはこのあまりこの観念的なことを理想的なとこをあまり喋れない
すごい生々しく具体的なことから事実を語るんです
だから私の講演いくら聞いても
あんまりこの超越した話やら神々の話はあんまり出てこないと思います
たまたま面白いんだからエピソードを言うかもしれませんだけど
でもそれはもう話のポイントというわけじゃないんです
そういう生々しいこと
ですから具体的に見てほしい
初めは家族という社会がある
これ 誰にでもありますね
小さい時 我々子供の頃
我々に社会があるんですよ
これは家族という社会なんです
それはその個人の家族であって
世界の他の家族とは違うものでしょう
私が生まれた家族が世界でどこにもある
ごく一般的な 理想的な
観念的な家族じゃないでしょうに
あれはある特定の家族であって
1個しかないんです 皆様の場合も同じで
皆様の家族がたったそれしかないんですよ
だからたった 1個しかないものは一般論として扱えるんでしょうかね
だから特定なんです だから世の中で
例えば家族は運勢やとかね
家族の在り方とか 理想的な家族は何であろうかとか喋ってるでしょ
いくら喋ってもなんか当てにならないんですよ
我々に模範にも勉強にもならないんです
ただガチャガチャ何か観念的なことを言ってるだけで
家族は崩壊しているんだぞとか
よくテレビでも聞こえますけど
時々家族が崩壊しているんだぞとか言うと
よくよく見るとどこかで事件が起きて
そこで親がバラバラになって
子供がバラバラになって
何とか問題が起きたっていうことで
だからといって日本の家族は全部そういう状態ではないんです
これがたった一つのケースで
だからド派手にニュースに取り上げているだけ
ある家庭でお母さんが子供を1人殺して旦那にも包丁で刺して逃げましたと
それでもう家庭は崩壊状態だ
母親は家庭を守るものではないか
今現代どうなってるんでしょうかと
あんないい加減な嘘を言ったっても
それはある1個の家族で起きた出来事なんですよ
だからといって もう至る所でお母さんたちがそんなことをやってるわけじゃないし
だから この家族論なんかは成り立たない
私が知ってるのは私が生まれた家族だけなんです
私は知っているのは自分の母親のことなんです
それで自分の母親がやってることは
世界中のどんな母親もやってるかというと
それは全くもあり得ない
次に教育ということを考えましょう
だから子供は家族で家族で育てられますけど
あれは普遍的な家族ではなくて
ある特定の家族ですよ
そんな家族である ある二人だけの人間2人と兄弟
僕らの場合は古い時代だから兄弟たくさんいるんですけど
兄弟たくさんいる あるいは日本だったら兄弟はない
もう親だけで3人だけの
そこで大きくなった人が世界に対して何でも知ってるんだぞと言っちゃうと
あまりにも笑い話なんですよ
自分の兄弟姉妹のことしか知らんだから
兄弟いたっても一人か二人で
それで兄弟論なんか語れるわけじゃないんです
それで教育も同じことなんですよ
それで私たちはいくらか大きくなったら学校に行くでしょう
そうするともっと大きい社会に出会うんではないかと勘違いして思ってるんです
これまた違う 行く学校が特定なんです
結局は 幼稚園であろうが
小学生であろうが 自分がある特定の何人かがいる幼稚園で
何人かがいる教室で ある一人のおばあさんかおじさんに会って
いろんなことを学んだりはする
そこでも小さな社会なんですよ
それでまた特定なんです
この学校の 1年生のクラスと別な学校の 1年生のクラスというのはかなり雰囲気が違うんです
先生によっても違うでしょうし
それで学校っていうのは
先生っていうのは毎週一人一人変えることないでしょうに
そうすると育てられませんだから
もう一年間ぐらいは一人はずっともうその子供たちに当たってるんです
だから学校教育を受けても
これがまた特定の社会であって
世界的な普遍的な社会ではございません
それは中学校に行っても同じことです
高校に入っても同じことなんです
どちらかというと 上に行けば行くほど社会が狭くなるんです
広くなるというよりも
幼稚園の子供たちはかなり楽しく遊んではいるんですけど
でもあの幼稚園のゲートからは外に出て行ってはいけないんです
時々始めたらもう庭にも行けないんです
中で閉じ込められているんです
それでもいくらか子供は自由に遊んではいるんですけど
どんどん高校生とかなってくると
もっと社会が狭いんです
狭くなるんです なぜかというと
高校生になると勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
いや そう何年も勉強できるわけないんです
自分が決まったものを勉強しなくちゃいけない
それには結構時間かかります
遊びたい年なんですけど
時間がないんです そうするとそれでも遊ぶんですよ
誰と遊ぶことを言うと
同じクラスのあの何人かの友達たちだけなんです
年下の子供たちも友達
しようとはしないんです
例えば 高校生は決して小学生の子どもを友達にはしないんです
かなりもう離れるんです
話しかけてきたってうるさいがあるんです
なんか鳥インフルエンザにかかっているような感じで
あっち行きなさいと それで高校生になっても小さい社会で
特定の社会で で みんなも次に考えるのは大学に入ったらもう社会人で一人前だと
もう全く違うんですよ
一旦入ってみたら また特定の社会で生きてるんです
そこでバイトやったりはしますね
大学生は だからって社会見えるわけじゃないんです
このバイトして社会見えないんですよ
例えばマクドナルドでバイトやってると言ったら
あの中に入っちゃって
もうハンバーグを紙に包んで出すだけの人生でしょうに
これは3時間か4時間って決まってるんだから
その間でそればっかりやってお金もらって帰るんです
で 我々思うんですよ そうやってバイトして
その後も社会勉強しているんだと
あれって社会勉強でしょうかと
ある決まってるワンパターンの生き方
なんとか否応なしにやって
ちょっと賞品もらうだけの話なんです
だからそれも特定の社会
次に それから我々には友達がいるんですね
その個人に友人という社会がある
友人という社会も同じことで決まってる
何人か友達であって 他の人とは友達になれないんだから
これまたある小さな特定な社会
それで私と私の友達の仲間と他の人とその人の友達の仲間というのは全く別世界
別な社会 合わないんです
これは友達作るとよくわかるでしょ
自分たちが自分たちの友達の仲間で
そのサークルの中にいるんであって
別なサークルに入ることは全くもしていないし
特定の社会です それから仕事に行く
会社という社会がある
これでやっと一人前になったぞと思ったら
これまた違う 会社っていうのは
ある特定の仕事をする特定の人物が集まっているところなんです
これが社会ではありません
特定っていうことは もっと面白い
おかしいことするために
変な社会と考え 言葉を入れ替えてみれば
私の友達の輪は変な社会だと
他の人から見れば なんであの変なグループはと
そこで私も他の人の友達グループ見て
なんだ変なグループですね
付き合いたくない もううるさい
我々こっち側に行きましょうと
という言葉で考えてください
だから社会っていうのは
会社っていうのは変なグループなんですよ
なんか変なことをする
まあ例えばヤマサキとかパン
パン作る会社に入ったりする
あの会社すごく変ですよ
パンばっかり作ってるんだから
他に何も作りません 自動車もパソコンも服も人間に必要なものはいっぱいあるのに
ヤマサキはパンばっかり作ってるんです
そこに入った人は このパンばっかり作ってる変なグループの中に入ってるだけ
だからそれが社会ではありません
ある変なグループなんです
だから一応 私たちは口先では言いますよ
このもう社会人になりましたと
一旦会社に入ったら 本当は社会人になってないんです
なんかどこかの変な社会
変なグループに入っただけなんです
こちらに座ります と えーと
ですから会社っていうのは普遍的な社会環境ではございません
明らかに変なグループなんですよ
我々のゴートゥーミー商事あるところの隣にマイクロソフト会社の本社があるんです
ばっかでかい会社で全く人は見えません
もう昼になってくると
なんかボロボロ服着ている
なんかもう肩が落ちている
若者はもう七 八人ぐらい
弁当買って ビニール袋にこうやって下向いて中に入るのが見えるんですよ
明らかに変な人々なんですよ
下見て 世間には何の興味もない
そこら辺のコンビニで弁当買って
こうやって下見てジュース買ってもすぐって中に入るんです
一旦入ったらもう出て行くまでまた何も見えません
で 彼らがもうコンピューターのプロ中のプロで
もうかなり才能あるんだから選ばれていますよ
若い若い人々はね だからといって
それがすごい変な社会なんですよ
世界のマイクロソフトで仕事をしているんだからといって
世界人になっているわけじゃないんです
それで結婚する 結婚したらどうなりますか？社会人になる
世界的に普遍的な相手と結婚するのではなく
ある特定の気に入ってる人と結婚するんですよ
普遍的な誰かと結婚するんじゃないんです
自分に気に入ってる誰か変な人と結婚するんです
だって他の人をその人選ばないでしょうに
だからみんな結婚する場合は自分に気に入ってる人と結婚するんです
それでまた変な社会が変な社会
ある特定の社会がそちらで現れますね
それで子供が生まれてくるでしょう
これまたおかしいことに
自分に生まれてくる子供もある特定の子供なのです
世間でどこにでもある子供とは違うんですよ
自分の子供はある特定の子供で
世界の子供とは明らかに違うんです
だから変な子供ですよ
どんな親もそれをどうやらそれちゃんと知ってますよ
うちの子はと言ったら
もう全く変な子って意味なんです
世界にあるごく普通にどこにでもいる子供って意味じゃないんです
だからうちの子はいつでも特別なんです
はい えーと では 電車に乗ってみましょうかと
電車に乗ってみたら社会に出会いますか？というと
特定の方面に向かって
出かけてる人々のみであるのです
電車に乗ってみたら もうなんというか
またある特定のどこかに行きたがって乗ってるグループしか会わないんですよ
社会に会うことができないんです
出勤電車の中の社会と長距離特急電車の中の社会が違うんです
でしょ 長距離走る特急電車に乗っちゃうと
すごい遠く田舎に行く人々のグループには入ります
出会いますけど 他誰にも会うことはできません
会社に行く人に出勤するで会うことはできません
通勤する子供たちにも会えません
出勤電車に乗っちゃったら
みんなもう会社に行く人々ばっかしで
すごく変なんです だから私も時々朝
朝早く ものすごく無理やりに電車に乗ってみたりすると
ものすごい人がいるんですよ
いっぱい みんな変なんです
ということは みんな自分自分たちの会社があって
そちらにもうとにかく早く行きたいっていうことでギューッとしてるだけのグループなんです
人は死ぬまである特定の社会にしか出会わない
そんなことで 一度も会うことはできないんです
社会に 我々はずっとある変な社会で
これ変な社会はいたくさんあります
それは変わるんです いくら変わっても変な社会で生きているんです
だから複数の社会があるっていうことは理解してほしい
これがもう世界中のことですよ
ここ日本だけの問題ではありません
世界中のことなんです
世界でどこにでも そういう地球規模で社会に出会って生活する人っていうのはいない
それであの死ぬと 例えば病院なんかに行くでしょ
病院ででも社会に出会いますかね
病院の中で 出会うはずないでしょ
みんな変人ばっかしでしょうに
病気にかかってる人と
この病気 その人々の面倒を見るグループと
それしかいないんです
医者も看護婦も変な人々で
もう病人に接するだけであって
もう元気な人を見たら別に挨拶しようともしないんです
そこに患者さんがいるならば
何々さんどうですか 調子どうですかとか聞いたりする
だから私たちも病気にかかったという何か変事になったならば
その社会に入れてくれるんです
だから病気になっても
もうまたそれしか起こってないんだから
もう死ぬ瞬間までも同じことで
まあ変な社会で生きてます
特定の世界で 個人に普遍的な社会に出会うことはできません
そのような社会は存在もしない
普遍的な社会っていうのは存在も際もしないんです
個人の社会論も その特定の社会に対する意見なのです
だから いろんな人々は社会について語ったりするでしょうし
大学でも社会学というね
まあかなり広い学問までありますけど
学問になるのかと 地理学などは学問になりますけど
社会学といって何勉強するんですかね
それで人間語る社会論も
まあどうってことない
その人が知ってる変な社会について語るんですよ
自分が経験してる変な社会について語ったっても
こちらにはあまり関係ないんです
だから 例えばこういうこと
ある夫婦が一度も夫婦喧嘩したことがないとします
そこでこんなこの夫婦の仲良く秘訣は何なのかと
それで他の人々もその秘訣聞きたくなるんですよ
この何夫婦というんですか？何鳥？オシドリ夫婦
オシドリ夫婦ふり そうして生活できる秘訣は何なのかと
そこでその人ちゃんと言いますよ
正直に真面目に でも その特別なあの二人の関係であって
他の夫婦にはそれは合わないんですよ
全くも合わない だからアドバイスを受けても
さらに夫婦喧嘩増えるだけでもう治ることはないと思います
例えば旦那がね こう言うかもしれません
私は結婚した時からもう奥さんにダーリンと呼んでいたんだと
奥さんは私のことをダーリンと呼んでるんだと
それで いつでも結婚した時の気分でいるんだそうと
あ いいことを教えてもらったと思って
皆さん家に帰って奥さんにダーリンと言ってみてください
どうなるかと あんた頭がおかしくなったんじゃないかと
うまくいかないんですよ
だから 特定の社会なんです
変な社会と理解すると分かりやすいんですよ
その夫婦は変な夫婦で
だからオシドリ夫婦で仲良くしていると
この夫婦はまた変な夫婦で喧嘩は絶えませんと
だから あの人からアドバイス聞いて
この人からアドバイス聞いて役に立ちません
と 9番目にいきます 複数の社会に合わせて複数の顔を持つ
持つ そこで私たちは特定な社会に特定な顔を見せるんです
自分が特定な社会にいるんだから
それ特定な社会に特定な顔を見せる
合わせる顔は同一ではダメです
それで例で考えましょう
ある男の子がいる その男の子の母親が結構うるさい
男は性格的にやんちゃ
うるさいんだから 母親はいつでもキャーキャーキャーキャーなんとか言う
それで子供は特定の顔を見せる
こんなうるさいおばさんだからということで
えらい頑固な顔を見せる
挨拶もしない いい加減で
頑固で 何か聞いたっても知りませんとかなんとか言ったりとかね
何か頼んだってもやってくれない
できませんと あんたやりなさいと
えらく態度でっかくて
もうもう母親に抵抗して家にいる
それは母親に見せる顔なんですよ
でも そのやんちゃなその男の子にも友達がいるんです
[咳]それで母親ってすごいひどい顔でひどい言葉で喋ってるのに
友達から電話がかかってきたらどうですかね
何のことなくペラペラペラペラすごい気分良く気持ちよくしゃべるんです
そちらに別な顔を見せるんです
同じ顔を見せちゃうと生きていられません
だから家で乱暴な性格の人も
友達のグループに入ったら乱暴っていうわけじゃないんです
そこで女の子の場合は
家では本当に出来のいいお嬢様でいる
それでちょっと出かけてくそうと言って
お母さんにも断り 出かけたところで全く違う性格
信じられない服に入れ替えるんです
コインロッカーで服をしまっておいて
それで電車でお化粧する
まるっきり別人に 生まれ変わる
生まれ変わって 渋谷であろうか
原宿であろうか いろんなところでもうもうやりたい放題
ふざけたい放題遊んだり
その時使う言葉なんかはもうもうもうもう何て言いますか
気が絶すほどもう気持ち悪い言葉で喋ってるんですよ
それで 1 日遊んで家に帰ると
また全部お化粧を落として
あの服なんか畳んでカバンに入れ込んで
すごく普通にただいまって言いながら家に入っちゃうんです
すごくいいお嬢さんで
男と女の場合はそういう性格のそういう 2つあります
男は家で乱暴ですけど
外ではすごいもう行儀はいいんです
まあそれは一つのケースで
みんなというわけじゃないんですけどね
まあだから一人一人別々だから
それで私たちはその々特定の社会に特定の性格を見せるんです
これが小さい時からももうもう習ってるんです
誰にどんな顔をすればいいかということ
ですから 見せる顔と見る顔がもうこれは別なポイントなんです
あの異なるものでなければいけません
それであの見せる顔と見る顔って 2つあります
これがぴったしはめないとまたうまくいかないんです
例えば母親がですごくうるさくて
もういつでも嫌な顔を見せると
それに対抗して子供はある別な顔を見せるんです
それ結構合ってます 合ってますから
ずっとそのことはできるようになるんです
まあでももっとわかりやすい例に
私はお見合いを例に出してみたんです
お見合いっていうのは
お見合いに行ったとする
それで二人が会うことなんですよ
そこで男は見せる顔を持っている
女の人に 女の人も男に見せる顔を持ってお見合いに行くんです
自分を全部持ってる顔じゃないんです
ある一個だけの顔 お見合いに行く時は
お見合いに行く女の子は
じゃああの男にこの顔を見せてやるそうと
ある特別な顔をかぶっていくんです
男もある特別な顔を見せてやるそうと
その顔をかぶって持っていくんです
そこで見せる顔と見る顔が成り立つんです
男から見れば女の顔は見る顔で
自分の顔は見せる顔で
女の子から見れば自分の顔は見せる顔で
男の顔は見る顔で それでハメますから
お互いによく見る それで考えてください
そのお見合いに女の人が行ったんだけど
その相手の代わりに私はこの妹を放り込んじゃうと
で 妹に頼む 君行ってお見合いしてくださいと
私の代わりに うまくいきますかね
そこで見せる顔と見る顔がなくなっちゃうんですよ
あるいはもう一人女の人がいて
その女の人もお見合いに行きたいんです
それで こちらにもお見合い現場があるんです
その女の子もこちらに入る
机があって 椅子 2つがあって
1つの椅子に女の子が座ってます
自分が連絡した男が来るまで
それでもう一人女の子がまた同じ現場にお見合い場に行く
行ったらこちら椅子空いてますから
では私が座りましょうと言うと
女二人がお互いに顔を合わせて座ったっても
これはお見合いにはなりません
だからいつでもこういう見せる顔と見る顔っていうのは 2つが成り立っています
で クラスに入る先生が生徒たちに見せる顔を持っていて
で 生徒たちは先生にある特別な顔を見せているんです
先生に見せる顔は全然友達には見せません
最近 ある小さな子供をじっと見ていたんです
じっとではなくて ちらっとなんですけど
その子はおばあちゃんと抱っこしてもらったり遊んだりする時でもニコニコと行く
父親が抱っこしてあげたりする時でも
ニコニコとそちらにも行く
それで母親抱っこする時
またその母親のところにもニコニコする
しかし まるっきりあの笑顔が違うんです
全くも違う おばあさんに見せる笑顔と父親に見せる笑顔と母親に見せる笑顔は見事に違う
不思議に思ったんです
そこで  第3者から見れば
子供の一番甘い美しい可愛らしい顔は母親にしか見せないんですよ
だから子供の本当に極端に愛らしい顔は見ているのは世の中で母親だけなんです
他誰を見ていないんです
見事に人間そうやってできてますよ
私たち気にしてないだけで
皆さんは自分の子供のことなら全部知ってるぞと威張りたいでしょうね
でも母に見せる顔はね
どう踏ん張っても父には見せません
喧嘩する時でも同じことですよ
父親と喧嘩する時見せる顔と母親と喧嘩する時の顔がまた違うんです
どちらでも嫌な顔なんですけど
それでも違う これからよく調べて研究してください
結構面白いんです だから個人が
それから個人の場合も
あのポイントはね まあ一応終了します
見せる顔と見る顔 だから一人の人間っていうのは何枚顔を持てばいいんでしょうかね
これ複数もう数えられないほど顔持たないと
で 個人が母に父に兄弟に違う顔を見せる
伴侶に子供に違う顔を見せる
友人に会社に違う顔を見せる
そうやって私たちは知らないほど顔を持っています
これ聞いてもわかりませんよ
あなたは顔いくつ持っているのかとかね
知ったものじゃないんですよ
[咳]これは決して知ったものではありません
そのその自分住んでいるある特定のある変な社会に適した顔を作っては見せる
だから顔っていうのは性格なんですよ
人格なんです これでももう大変なことなんです
我々の性格って何なのか
人格って何なのかと もう無限にあります
一人の人間 一人の個だとは言えないんですよ
人間はもうもう複数の無数の顔
無数の性格 無数の人格を持っている
従って 複数な人格がないと常識的な生き方はできません
だから訳も分からない人格でなきゃもう生きていられませんよ
中途半端でいい加減で訳も分からない
どうにもならん もう複数な人格でなきゃ
我々にはこの社会では生きていられません
[咳]で そういうふうに言っても
この社会といってもそんなのは存在しませんよ
自分がある小さな社会で特定な社会で生きているんだから
それなのに複数な人格が必要なんです
そこでまあ今日のテーマの基本的なところは終わります
それから変身の技っていう
だからその場でその場で顔を変えないと TPO
に応じて適切に顔を入れ替える能力は大事なのです
みんな立派なね 何役者でしたっけ？歌舞伎役者でないと
だから歌舞伎の場合は男であろうと見事に女に化けるでしょうに
若いのに老人に化けるでしょうに
そんな感じで我々もこのTPOに応じて化けないと
別な性格を持たないとダメなんですね
だからその能力は必要なんです
入れ替え上手な人こそ社会的成功者なのです
社会で成功している人っていうのは
この入れ替え上手 見事に化ける
それで成功します 例えばこういうふうに考えてください
例えば 母親にものすごいわがままの顔をケンカばっかりする
ものすごい嫌な顔を見せる男の子が
同じ態度で友達のグループに入っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
友達にも同じ態度であれやれこれやれ
お前何やとか言っちゃうともう殴られますよ
時々殺されることもあるんだから
だからそれはもう大変なことで
そこで子供は友達にはすごい立派なそれなりの顔を見せるわ
母親にはすごいわがままな顔を見せるわ
父親が厳しいんだったら
父親には違う顔を見せる
その男は 父親がいろいろ喋ると
じっと下を見てよく聞いてるふりをしている
そうすると父親もまあまあ母親とは喧嘩するんだけど
俺が言うことを聞いてくれると
そこで無事解決する もう建て前だけですけど
で 子供はセーフでしょ
そこでそのいい加減な男の子は女の子と付き合うと
まあ優しい男の子で もう気がすぐ利く子で
いろいろ冗談を言うわ
いろんな面白いことをするわ
いろんなところに連れてって遊ぶわとかね
そこで付き合ってる女の子には別な顔を見せる
そこでどちらでもその子はセーフなんです
トラブル起こらないで
だからそういう生き方ですよ
社会の成功っていうのは
社会人として成功するっていうことは
そういう生き方なんです
でも引っかかるのはこの社会人としてというその言葉なんです
それがありえないんです
社会人はいません 変人はいます
変な社会人 変なグループに入っている
その中で成功するんです
そこで私たちは勉強しなくちゃいけないのは
この顔を淡々とかなり速さで入れ替える技なんです
あの舞台演劇の場合でも
かなり大胆に衣装を変えたりするでしょ
こう時々まあまあ信じられないほど見事な早さでもう全部変わったりする
いろいろ目をごまかしたりする
例えば舞台の上でも衣装を変えたりする場合は
お客さんの気持ちは別なところに引かせておいて
そちらに釘付けておいておくんです
例えば歌ってる場合は
歌ってる人がもういきなり衣装も変えて変身したいんです
歌の 2番目のフレーズを歌う前に
そこで何するかというと
まずド派手に踊って歌う
それセクション終わったら演奏が始まるんです
それでその人は演奏の方にバトンタッチするんです
そこで各人々はまたいろいろ技を見せて
ギタリストはなんとか変なことをやって
ドラムリストはまた何かやったりして
まあいろいろ前に出たり
後ろに下がったり 飛び飛び上がったり
いろんなことをして演奏が伸びるんですよ
その間であの踊り見ている間って
この人はちゃんと変身して
パッと光が当たるとまた別の人になってるんです
そういう風にいろいろ技を作って変身技術をね
詰まってます そこで我々は喜びますね
素晴らしいと あの舞台は
だからその我々も人生の顔を変える技っていうのを学ぶ
学んだ方がいいんです
まあそれ まあ一応仏教はそういうことを言ってるんです
はい そこで大根役者のこと
あの 6種類に分けたんです
1番目は入れ替えできない
いつでも もう誰に来たって同じ顔
これが病気ですね 精神的な問題なんです
例えば ある男がいつでもお母さんに対してはすごい甘い顔を見せて
お母ちゃんなんとかなんとかと言ったりする
その子は電車に乗って
何か隣おばあちゃんが座ってたらお母ちゃんと言っちゃうと
びっくりするんじゃないんですかね
お母ちゃん この何々駅はどこですか？と
みんなちょっとびっくりしますよ
だから顔を変えてないんだから
隣の人に駅を聞きたければ
おばあさんどこですか？なんとか聞かなくちゃいけないんでしょうに
その時は別な顔を見せなくちゃいけない
だからこの顔を入れ替えできないと言えば病気なんで
明らかに病気なんで すごい問題です
それから入れ替え間違う
これ大変なことなんですよ
入れ替えが間違うと みんな結婚している男性は奥さんに見せる顔があって
また付き合っている誰かが女の人を見て
その人に見せる顔という顔 2つ持っているでしょうに
ちょっとでも間違っちゃうと 2つもダメになっちゃうんです
不倫している女の人に自分が奥さんに見せる顔を見せちゃうと
その人に追い出されます
家に帰って不倫している女の人に見せる顔を見せちゃうと
奥さんに追い出されます
入れ替え間違っちゃうともう大変なことになるんです
でもこれで大体しょっちゅう起きますよ
しょっちゅう起きます
しょっちゅうトラブルが起きます
まあまあ あまりにもすごい軽い例で説明すると
会社でかなり立場があって
部下がいっぱいいて しっかりした人間で仕事をするお父さんがいる
管理はすごい上手 人の管理
だから会社では結構もう立場がよろしい
それと同時に忙しいんだから
家では年頃の男がいて
もうなかなかもう言うことを聞かない
母親には管理できない
その時もう父親はもうあまりにも母親に言われて言われて
なんとか子供に言いなさいよとか言うと
本人がよしとわかって
ちゃんと食卓に座って息子を呼んで
こちらに座りなさいっていろいろアドバイスする
その時 知らんうちに自分が会社の課長の顔になっているんです
会社の課長で部下がたくさんなっても
ただ指をさしてあんたこんなことやってはあかんぞとかね
そうではないでしょうとかね
なんとか言ったりする顔になっちゃって
殴られる可能性あります
子供に 顔が変わっちゃうと
それは大体は怒る 怒る場合あります
会社で喋っている調子で
息子も大人だから 見てみたっても大人の男で
大人らしく喋るではないかと思ったのは良かったんだけど
大人同士で知らんうちに会社の顔がかぶってるんです
で うまくいかない だからこの入れ替え間違いっていうのは
どなたの人生でも まあそっち起こるんです
その時は必ずトラブルが起きているはずなんです
3番目の人っていうのは
自分が好きな顔にする
相手に合わせるんじゃなくて
自分が好きな顔をするんです
例えば気が立っている
気が立っているのは何かに対して気が立っているでしょう
それに対してすごいひどい鬼の顔を見せてもいいんです
そこで誰か隣のどなたかが通りかかって
この家に何か尋ねる その人にすっごい気が立って怒った顔を見せちゃうと
これおかしいでしょうね
でも俺が怒ってるんだからしょうがないではないかという態度を取ったりする
そういう風に頑固な人々いるんですよ
例えば授業中なのに 全然真面目な真剣な顔じゃなくて
ふざけて口を開けて ゲームやってる時の顔はゲーム好きだからその調子でいると
これすごく迷惑でうまくいかないんです
いくら言っても聞いてくれない
真面目に勉強しなさいとかね
そういう風に自分好きなことだけやるっていう意味は
自分好きな顔で生きているということなんです
学校に行ってもゲームばっかしやってる子は
家ででも学校ででも自分好きな顔で生きてるんです
会社でもカンカン怒って怒鳴りっぱなしでいる人が
家に帰っても奥さんやら子供にカンカン怒鳴りっぱなしで生活しちゃうと
この本人は自分好きな顔で生きているだけ
それで人生成功するわけじゃないんです
それが頑固ということは自己中心ということ
相手には構わないということで
[背景音楽]相手に顔を合わせて返信させます
それから入れ替えは下手な人もいますね
入れ替えはするんだけど
下手 バレバレ まあまだ子供の例で説明します
子供は本当に叱るべき悪いことしたとします
怒鳴らなくちゃいけない
そこで父親が怒鳴っただけで子供は聞いてくれない
ですから すごく優しい父親の顔をせなくちゃということで
よしやるぞと思って すごい甘い顔声で自分の子供を呼んで「こっちおいで
どう君元気？」とかなんとか言うと
うまくいかない そんなこともうバレバレ
簡単にバレちゃいます
子供には それで子供が「何か言いたかったらハッキリ言いなさい」って言うんです
こちらせっかく優しい顔を被って頑張ったんだけど
言って それ下手だから
同じケース 例えば私がやる場合は
もうとんでもなく怒鳴りますよという気持ちあるんだけど
入れ替えますよ じゃあ優しい顔でやるぞと
バレないようにします
具体的には例えば これは全然関係ないような感じで
まあまあまあこれ何とか叱りなさいよと言ったって気にしないで
あのね あれあれ見たのあれ面白いぞとかなんとか別なことを言うんです
お前 なんとかのゲームやったことあるの？あれできるの？で
私にちょっと教えてくれと言っちゃうと
子供はいきなりそれを騙されちゃって
あ そうだ これはねとか言って偉そうなことで教えてくれたりする
そうするとこちらもすごいもうニコニコと笑いながら
まあこんな言ったってね
ああ言った それ子供はやっぱり優しいんだなこの人はと
それでね まあそれにお前な
この間やったことはね
あれはけしからん と何のことなく言えるんです
子供に反論もできなくて
もう受けるしかないんです
だから上手に入れ替えないと
これ下手な入れ替えは結構あります
皆様にもみんなに家族がありますから
そういう入れ替え下手で失敗したことというのはいくらでも身に覚えあると思います
で 前の顔を外さないでその上にかぶる場合もあります
これはいつでも混乱招くんですよ
で まあこれすごい これもすごい大事なポイントなんですけど
なかなか例が思い出せないんです
あまりいい例じゃないんですけど
例えばお母さんが旦那さんと喧嘩したとします
その時は遠慮なくしなくて
ものすごい激しく喧嘩して
怒鳴ったり 厳しい言葉を喋ったり言ったりして
で そこの途中で もう喧嘩がなんか終わったそうな時間なんですけど
そこで子供がなんとか言う
それでまあ旦那さんがお茶入れてくれと言ったりする
そうするともう怒鳴られたと
入れてあげません 勝手にしなさいよと
で それで子供もお母ちゃん喉が渇いたと言う
そこで前の顔をかぶった
あ 子供言うんだから子供にあげなくちゃいけないってことなんですけど
子供は冷蔵庫に手が届かない
いきなり引っ張っちゃって
はい それにやってはあげます
自分が子供には親切やと勘違いしてるだけで
結局前の顔の上に 2番目の顔を被ってるんです
あれを外すてないんです
で もっと大人の世界で言えば
まあ例えば 会社で自分がすごく失敗しました
それで怒鳴られた ものすごく嫌な気分でいる
それはその顔なんです
そこで家に帰ったら 子供は何かゲームをやろうと父親を呼ぶ
それで子供はまあせっかく子供と遊ぶのはもうやらなくちゃいけないということで
ではじゃあやりましょうという感じでやるんだけど
子供にはいい親父でゲームの相手にしてあげる顔を被ってはいるんだけど
下にあの会社であった出来事のあの感情の顔はそのままでちょっときついんですよ
うまくいかない 穏やかにならない
そこで早くもいい 疲れたんだからもう一人で遊びなさいとか何とか言って追い出したり
何とかする それに子供は怒る可能性もある
時々結構あるんです 我々はこの前の顔はかぶったままで
別な別な顔をかぶろうとしてるんです
いわゆる前の感情はそのままにしておいて
それは引きずりながら別な仕事をしようとする
これで結構失敗します
人生は  6番目 いくつかの顔を引きずってくる
これが不安定な性格 これがこういうこと
あの あるグループに接しなくちゃいけない
だからその特定なグループ
その変なグループに見せるべき顔があるんです
それの顔が自分が心から表に出すんだけど
いろんな顔がもう絡み合っちゃって出てくるんですよ
これ結構大変なんです
まあ例えば笑わなくちゃいけないとこかもしれませんだけど
もう笑ったりもするんですけど
また別な顔ももう紛れ込んできて
怒ったりも全く関係ないことを言ったり
いろんなことをトラブったりするんです
いくつかの顔も あの被るべき顔と一緒にもうもう
絡み合ってくるんです
この経験もだいたい人間にはあります
それが自己管理できない状態
はい それでこの大訓訳者の 2番目で
一般的な まあ一般 一般の人も 5と６を気をつけた方が良い
時々病気な人のことも言ったんだから
例えば 1番目は病気でしょうし
入れ替えが全く違う入れ替えにするのは
まあこれはまああまりにもアホな人しかしませんし
自分好きな顔だけ見せてやるぞと
俺は俺は俺で生きてやるぞっていうのは頑固
それもあまり言いませんですけどね
でも我々はよくやっちゃうのはこの五
五番目 いわゆる前の顔を外せない
その上に別な顔を被っちゃう
だから座りが悪いんです
人生として ほんのちょっと前で怒ったことがありまして
それからもう一般の方々の前で何か発表したり
何かしなくちゃいけない
その場合 すぐ丁寧な顔を見せなくちゃいけない
でも 怒ったことの顔も中に入っちゃうと
この丁寧なおとなしい顔の据わりが良くないんですよ
ちょっともうすれたり
いろいろそこら辺は我々大人が気をつけた方がいいんですね
六番目で書いたのは このいろんな顔を引きずってくること
このテレビで政治家の話でも
なんとか時々見ると この政治家だから人気を買わなくちゃいけないんだから
一生懸命ニコニコと顔をしてるんですけど
記者の人々はちょっとちょっと失礼な台本を失念しちゃうと
いきなり顔変わっちゃって怒ったりして
で ちらっと口が滑っちゃうんです
それで 1時間のレポートなのに
放送するのはあの滑った言葉だけが最悪状態
それがいくつかの顔を引きずっているんだから
政治家の場合は必ずそれがあるんですよ
裏で商売でしょうし 表向きは命かけて国民を守っているでしょうし
いろんなことをやってますからね
それから ライバルの足を引っ張るために
またいろんなカラクリをやらなくちゃいけないし
だからもうかなり精神的な力がないと政治家としてうまくかないんです
[咳払い]で 五と六っていうのは気をつけた方がいい
前の顔を外せないとは
前の人間関係の感情を忘れないで新しい人に対応することです
前の感情は今会っている人には関係がないのです
で 若い女の子がもう付き合ってる男の子とすっごく喧嘩して
もうカンカンヒステリーになっているんだと
その時は別な仕事関係の友達が来る
この仕事の話をするために
その人にももうヒステリーであんた何よとか言っちゃうと
もうおかしい 見所でしょうに
その人にはそれが関係ない
もう自分が自分付き合ってる男と喧嘩したことも
えらいヒステリーになった
わがままになった それ関係ない
仕事は別な顔 そこがちゃんと覚えておかないと
これかなり技ですよ  1 分前ものすごく怒っていて
今すごくニコニコ顔で対応しなくちゃいけないという
これ大根役者にはできませんよ
人生は それで例は夫婦喧嘩をして子供に八つ当たりする
で いくつかの顔が引っかかってくる場合も自己管理できなくて
入ってるんですか？まあ
その場合も自己管理できないということで
[咳払い]で まあ早く終わりにしましょう
複数の性格について仏教のアドバイス
様々な性格は自分だと思うことも
また本来の自分はそれと全然違うと思うことも良くない
ちょっと難しくなるかもしれませんだけど
それで私という人に数えられないほど性格あるでしょ？子供には
男の子供には一つの顔
女の子供には別の顔 おばあさんには別の顔
おじいさんには別の顔とか
そうやってもう人間というのはたくさんもう性格を持っている
それが全部自分自身だと思っちゃうと困るんですよ
あるいはこの数えられないほどごちゃごちゃほどごちゃごちゃの性格
全部まとめて一体にして
これが私ですよと どちらでも良くない
それでもちょっとわかりにくいね
例えばある人に怒ったりして
また同じ人に別な時は優しくしたりして
それで あんたはある時は優しくて
ある時は怒ったりして
もう何ですかね その性格
それはその通りですと
怒る時は怒ると 優しくする時は優しくする
それは私の性格ですと
泣く時は泣くと 怒鳴る時は怒鳴ると
ケチる時はケチますと
で そんな風にこの自分のバラバラの性格はその時その時しっかりやっていくんだという考え方もあるいは
自分の性格がありまして
その都度その都度自分がそういう風に見せてるんだと
いわゆるこの 花立てるあれ
なんて言いますか あの
皿 献花？お皿ありますね
で 大きく花を立てるためには
お皿みたいな何かもの必要でしょうし
だからそれで立てる花っていうのはみんなバラバラ
別々なものでしょうね
葉っぱももうね いろいろ枝まで挿したりするでしょうね
時々人工的に何かをつけたりもするでしょうし
そんなもんだと私は 私がいて
その場でその場で花も立てておくわ
枝も挿しておくわ プラスチックの何かも挿しておくわ
もうボール紙も必要だったら入れておくわとかね
何が文句あるのかと 全部私はきちんとまとめているんだと
いう性格も良くない これ性格に入れ替えてみてください
だから １本１本別々私だというのも良くない
全部皿でまとめているんだよという考え方も
仏教から見れば良くないんです
自分だとアイデンティティを持つと
感情が引きずって総合的に性格が悪くなるんです
例えば怒ったのも自分でそれなりの訳があって怒ったんだと
笑ったのも自分でそれなりの訳があって笑ったんだと
親切にしたのも自分でそれなりの訳があって親切にしたんだと
あの人を騙していくらかお金取ったの私で
その場合はその人を騙さなくちゃかんなから騙してやったと
で 人に盛大におごって
おごってご飯食べたのは
それはそれで私その場でそれでやりましたと
そうやっていろいろ性格が自分自身でやるべきことだからやりましたと威張っちゃうとどうなるかというと
この この感情を引きずるんですよ
怒った時の感情も 笑った時の感情も
まあ何て言いますか この懐が大きくて
みんなにいろいろ接待した時の感情も
あるいは友達とご飯食べて自分がお金払わないでそれっとこそっと逃げた時の感情も
何だかんだでまとめて
私は全部それでやと思うっちゃうと
その それで性格が悪くなるんです
感情を引きずるんです
[終始背景音楽]それからでも簡単になるかどうかはわかりませんだけどね
こっちは難しいね 言ってることは違うと思うと自己責任にかける
次のポイントにとにかく行きます
で その時怒ったんだけど
別に私は怒りっぽい人間ではございませんと
その時笑ったんですけど
いつでもニコニコ笑う人間ではありませんと
ただたまたまその時やっただけやというふうに
そういうふうな態度をとると
バラバラ性格 責任がなくなっちゃうんです
自己責任 責任に欠けてしまうんです
結構みんなそうやりますでしょう
あれは酒飲んで酔っ払ってやったことだからとかね
酒飲んで酔っ払って その時の性格だから
今違うんだと 私は 今私は違うと言ったっても
酒飲んでやったことはどうするんでしょうかね
それでそんな言い訳しちゃうと
責任に欠けちゃうんですね
結局は顔なんであろうと責任を負たなくちゃいけない
その場で正しく対応して
次の場面にそれを持っていかない方がよろしいのです
これがやり方なんです
その場でその場で正しく対応する
相手が子供だったら 日本語も使い方も何からも身振り手振りも全部子供に合わせて
見事に子供とうまくいって
その問題を解決して 次に会社の商売の話をしなくちゃいけないんだったら
しっかりした日本語でしっかりした理性で淡々とそれを喋らなくちゃいけないんです
そこで会社で大事な相談をやってる間でも
あの子供にと遊んでいた雰囲気
心にあると チェック 危険なんです
あれは綺麗さっぱり忘れなくちゃいけないんです
きちんと忘れて 次のことにハッとする
だからもう引きずらないで完璧に変身しなきゃダメなんです
それから仏教の論理 今までの説明
あの複数の性格は因縁の法則なのです
我々複数の性格を持っているということは
仏教を言っているインチキな話ではなくて
これはお釈迦様がおっしゃっている因縁論なんです
原因条件によって結果が変わるんです
それが因縁論なんです
例えば相手が子供たちで
なんかどこかでそのグループは行こうとしているんだけど
地図はちょっと読めなくて困っていると
その時は大人がその条件によって性格変わるんですよ
あら これは子供たちではないかと
子供たちはどこかでどこかに出かけているんではないかと
地図まで持っていて で
子供たちは地図を読めなくて道がわからないと困っているんだと
それで じゃあ君たちはどこに行きたいの？ああそう
じゃあ面白いでしょうねとかね
で 学校はどこ？とかね
[音楽]そこでグループ何人がいるの？と聞きながら
これはですね この道をまっすぐ行って
それから右に曲がって
こういうふうに行けばちゃんと行けますよと言わなくちゃいけない
そこで その条件によって自分があの子供の面倒を正しく見られる立派な大人になりました
そのままママ店に入る
何か買い物するために
その時条件変わるでしょ
そこで性格も変わるんです
子供に見せた性格じゃないんです
店に入ったところで 店がもう品物あるところはわからなくなっちゃって
それで誰かに何々はものはどこにどのどんなフロアでフロアで売ってるんでしょうかとかって聞かなくちゃいけない
それで私はどんな性格かということは
その時の因縁 条件なんです
だから因縁だけでもないんです
条件も必要なんです 例えば子供が道を聞くと
自分も本当にすごく疲れているという条件もある
あるいはもう自分がバスに乗らなくちゃいけないんだけど
バスが来て止まってる状態条件
その場合はものすごく早く一言葉で言ってあげて
バスに乗るでしょうに
だから性格っていうのはそうやって因縁条件によって変わるものなんです
それから因縁条件がなくなったら
その結果が消える 引きずってはいけないんです
子供に早い早口で淡々とあの行く行きたいところに行ける方法を教えてあげて
走ってバスドアが閉めるほんのちょっと前にバスに乗り込んだと
乗り込んだ時でもあの気分でいる必要はないんです
もうバスに入ってるんだから
それで違う性格でいなくちゃいけないんです
だから性格は消えていくんです
新しい原因 条件によって新しい結果が現れる
性格は常にこのように流転するのです
で 普通の人間の問題は
性格が流転すると分かってないんですよ
ものすごい流転するんですね
次から次へと はい しかし
理性を働かせて良い結果が出るように自己管理することもできるのです
因果論で言えば 何か性格はしょうがないではないかということにもなります
例えば バスに乗ろうとしたところで
人が何かすごい邪魔をしたんだと
本人はバスに乗らないのに
その前で何か誰かと喋っている
そうするとちょっと怒るでしょうに
ちょっとどきなさいよと
別なところで喋りなさいよと言いたくなるでしょうに
で 因果論だけになっちゃうとそうなるんです
その時ちょっと気持ち悪くなって怒ったりするのはもう避けられないんだと
例えば 電車に乗ってあの手すりを捕まっていると
電車がブレーキをかけちゃう
で 自分がグラッとするんだけど
隣にハイヒールの靴を履いていた女の人も体がグラッとして
自分の足の上に 自分の足を踏んでしまうと
これが包丁で刺したほど痛いんだから
もう嫌になるでしょうに
それでしょうがないではないかと
それで条件変わったんだからと
しかし そうじゃないんです
いい結果出せるように自己管理できるんです
ハイヒールで足を踏まれたんですけど
なんだこの女はと思わないで
別のアプローチすることもできます
で 向こうは女の子だから
もう大体もうバランスは崩れるのは決まってるし
大丈夫ですか？と相手に聞くとかね
自分が大丈夫じゃないのにね
そういうこともできます
ある場面で出せる顔が必ず一つしかないと思うのは無知な態度です
出せる顔一つしかないと思ってはいけないんです
それも喧嘩になります
例えば奥さんがもう明日誕生日パーティーやりましょうというと
奥さんが決まってるんです
それで旦那さんが「あーこれでよかった
楽しい楽しい」とかね 「
じゃあ私もプレゼント買ってきますよ」とか
という風に奥さんが初めから旦那が出すべき顔をこれやと決まってると問題が起こるんです
旦那さんが「そんなところじゃないんです
私は明日ものすごく仕事が入ってあって
もしかすると徹夜になるかもしれません
だから君らパーティーやりなさい」と言った途端
奥さんがものすごくもうカッとなって怒る
何故でしょうか？と そうなるのは
この あれ 出せる顔が一つしかないと思っているだからなんです
たくさんあります 一つの場面でどんな顔をにしようかなという風に選べる顔がいくつかあるんです
で いくつかの顔の選択ができます
それを理解して 常に良い顔を選ぶようにするのです
もっと単純な例で 例えば子供がちょっとうるさくふざけて家で遊んだりしている
それで自分には顔がいくつかあります
怒鳴る 怒鳴って 「うるさい
いい加減にしなさい 」
あるいはアドバイスする 「
これ遊ぶことをやめてちゃんと勉強しなさい」と
あるいはもう一つ顔があるんです
まあ子供は家でふざけて遊ぶのは子供のね
家は子供の城だから じゃあもうじゃんじゃんやりなさいよと
で やらせる顔もある あるいはもっと大人しく
ちょっと昨日聞いた物事をわかる
物事を理解できる わかり屋の顔もあります
物分かり屋の顔 その時は子供たちに「まああの
遊ぶ時はね 家族はみんなのところでしょう？ですから
まあ君たちは遊んだ場合は
他の大人には邪魔してはいけない
その人々にも の家だからね
だからそれぞれみんなでみんな民主主義で
他人に邪魔をしないで遊びましょう」という
なんか物知り屋の顔もあります
だから 子供はふざけて遊んでいる場面で
自分がそういういくつかの顔の中で一つ選んだ方がいいんですよ
人間がいきなりパッと一つ選んで対応しますけど
その顔がいつでも違うんです
感情だから うるさい 黙れという
その場合は 子供がうるさくて遊んでいるんだから怒るということは一番最初に出てくる顔なんです
いきなりそれを使うんです
それ無知なんですよ あの顔っていうのは箱で来るんで
セットで その場でその場で
その中にいくつかあるんですよ
できれば一番後ろにある顔を被った方が正しいんです
一番上にある顔じゃなくて
みんな一番上にある顔がぶつかるんです
で これが仏教でいうアドバイスなんです
ある場面に私はどんな性格を見せるべきかということで
自然に性格いくつかのセットが出てくるんです
このセットの中からぴったし
いいもの 良い結果が出る顔を選ばなくちゃいけない
まあ順番で言うのは難しいんですけど
大体一番最初に最初に見えてくる顔は被らない方がいいんです
これはもう決まって間違っているんです
もうちょっとほんの微妙な瞬間
自分の心を見ると 次の顔もあるのは見えます
それで 2番目  3番目の 4番目の顔だったらとてもいいんです
そこでまたポイントを変えます
エゴという問題 で かなり派手に変えますから
ほんのちょっと休みましょう
はい そろそろ始めます
よろしいですか 大体この我々はいつでもこの一般論で
観念でばっかし物事を考えるんだから
よく世の中に言うんですよ
人間には魂がある 自我がある
自分という何かある で
あのカタカナでエゴっていうのは悪い意味なんですが
ローマ字のエゴは哲学的な意味なんです
悪い意味じゃないんです
イゴイストとか言葉使っちゃうと我儘って意味なんですけど
エゴでも でもイゴっていうのは自我って意味なんです
自分の魂なんです 決して変わらない自分という意味なんです
イゴっていうのは そこで今までの説明とイゴの問題は何なのかと
今までの説明見ると 自分というのはもうわけもわからないでしょうに
性格は 私たち自分自分というものはもうわけもわからない
もう何するかわからない
その場でその場でもう顔が変わってしまいますから
それが普通な自然な自分なんです
変な自分じゃないんです
普通な常識な人間というのは
もう性格はわけもわからない
ごちゃごちゃ変わる それでイゴって何なのか
それで考えられるのは
そのごちゃごちゃ変わる性格
全部統一する自分としてすべて一箇所にまとめるのかと
そういう自分の性格がありますかと
だから私はハテナ入れたのはあるのかということなんです
あるって意味じゃないんです
だからカンカン誰かと怒って喧嘩している時は
その怒って喧嘩する自分も
ものすごく優しくする自分もという自分というのを
どこかで一定的なところから管理されているのかと
あるいは複数の性格が合体すると
それが自分ですか？と
怒る自分も笑う自分も泣く自分も
いろんなことがまとめて合体して
それが自分で自分のエゴなのかと
しかし 仏教から見れば
その 2つも邪見なんです
間違いの考え方です で
なんで簡単に邪見というのかというと
この物事というのは生々しくなきゃ科学的じゃないんです
観念的ではダメなんです
観念で もしかすると総合する何かあるでしょう
花立てる時の皿みたいなものというかね
もしかするとあるでしょうではなくて
あるのかと あるんだったら出してくれというのは仏教の立場なんです
もしかすると天国で誰かが管理しているかもしれません
そんなのはもう相手にしない
仏教は いるんだったら連れて来いと
具体的でなきゃダメなんです
だから邪見と言うんです
それはエゴという妄想概念です
私たちはエゴがあるんだという妄想概念があるんですよ
だって怒ったのも自分で笑ったのは自分だから
まあそれは俺だよという感じで
だから俺がいるんだという
すごい簡単に決めてしまう
しかし 事実は何なのかというと
実は全てが無常で流転しているのです
だからそれをわかる わかるために一番やりやすい方法っていうのは
正直に自分を見ることなんです
それしか方法ないんです
本当に正直に自分って何なのかと
そこで電車に乗っている
乗っている自分が何なのか
家でドアも閉めてソファに転がっている自分って何なのかと
それと電車に乗っている自分というのはまるっきり同じなのか
何か本を読んでいる時の自分と別な時の自分もまるっきり同じですかと
買い物している自分 食べている時の自分
料理作っている時の自分とかね
そうやってはっきりと正直に自分を観察すると
自分がえらく変身しているということが見えてくるはずなんです
うまく変身できなくて
できない時はイライラするんですよ
例えば面白い本があって
本ばっかり読みたい時は
子供がもう服を引っ張ったりして遊ぼう遊ぼうと言うとイライラするんです
今忙しいんだから一人で遊んでとか何とか言うんだけど
気分的にはイライラ 変身できない
変身できる場合は全くイライラもないんですよ
見事に変身している だから自分を観察すると
自分が全く別人だと その時その時見えるはずなんです
だからですよ おとなしくアパートで住んでいる人が突然人を殺したりするとかね
そこでみんなあ 信じられない
あの人はなんで人を殺したんでしょうかとかね
そんないい加減なことを言ったって
そんなのはあり得るんだから
普段はそういう条件なかったんだから人を殺してないし
でもある日は条件変わっちゃって人を殺してしまったんです
だから人を殺した時のその人の人格と
普通のアパートでバイトして生活している時の人格と
それぞれ違うんです 自己愛
それを覚えておいてください
自己愛 生存欲という感情がすべての顔に性格に入っているのです
うん？飛ばした？うん
ああ そうですね で 基本的に貪瞋痴という感情はあらゆる顔を作り出すのです
私たちはどんな顔をしても
基本的な感情 3つがありまして
この貪瞋痴という そこからこの複数な無数な顔を作るんですよ
これで貪瞋痴といえばだいたい 3つで同じだから
そこで我々は誤解するんですよ
エゴがあるんだ 自分自我があるんだそうとかね
感情が似ているので変わらない自分がいると錯覚するのです
すぐに 感情が似てるんですよ
例えば子供に優しい顔を見せる時でも欲なんですよ
楽しいんだから そこで子供には何か大人らしく
優しい大人として顔を見せる
でも楽しいんですよ あれも欲です
そこで綺麗なお姉ちゃんも見える
振り返ってみたら それで綺麗なお姉ちゃんにもちょっとニコって優しい顔を見せるんですよ
それも欲なんです しかし
子供に対する欲とお姉ちゃんに対する欲っていうのは結構違うでしょうに
子供の場合 ああ可愛いってぐらいの欲であって
お姉ちゃんに対してはもっと違う
セクシーだと思っているんだから
しかし 欲には変わりがないんですよ
だからその欲の感情 怒りの感情
無知の感情が何か似ているんだから
私たちは自分がある 魂がある
エゴがあると錯覚するんです
それからまた自己愛 生存欲
死にたくないという気持ちですね
も人を支配しているのです
我々どんな顔を見せても
どんな顔を見せて遊んでも
ずっと自己愛という あのものも付いてるんです
自己愛があるんだから怒る
自己愛あるんだから笑うということ
自分のため それから生存欲がありますね
死にたくないという で
それでずっといろんな顔で大根役をやってます
これもエゴ自我の実態なのです
まあエゴと自我っていうのはこの貪瞋痴か自己愛か生存欲か
それでそこら辺なんです
はい 自己愛 生存欲という感情がすべての顔に性格に入っているのです
よく覚えてください 我々にはもうもう何百億ぐらい性格を持っていたっても
すべて自己愛入っています
生存欲入っています 自己愛
生存欲という糸で複数な顔性格を 1本の輪にするのです
だからまるっきりバラバラの性格
怒る性格やら笑う性格はバラバラなのに
怠ける性格とかね 踏ん張る性格とか
これものすごい質的にも違う
バラバラ なのにこの複数の性格を我々は自己愛という 1本の糸で繋げているんです 1
本の糸で繋げて輪にしているのです
これで性格の問題は解決できなくなっているのです
だから我々のは性格の問題を解決できないんです
繋げているんです 自己愛
だから仏教はその渇愛切ってみなさいと
それで解決するんだよ
はい それからもう一応話は終わり
ちょっとまああの 序論というか
まあエピローグですね
一体私の性格って何なのかと
それだったら 俗世間では性格
パーソナリティ キャラクターという言葉を使うことは普通なのです
俗世間ではよく言うんですね
人のパーソナリティ キャラクター
性格という言葉はね しかし
一定した性格はない 誰にも
あの人のキャラクターはこれやと言ったっても
そんな一定してない 人には基本的に感情の傾きがあります
それによって現れる顔も変わるのです
これはそういう こういうこと
我々には何となくこの感情の傾きがあります
わかりやすいですよ ちょっと怒りっぽいとかね
いつでも笑顔でいるとかね
あの人は怒ったって笑ってるんだぞとかね
あの人はなんかもうちょっと怠けっぽいとか
そういう怒りっぽい 怠けっぽい
なんか欲張りとか何とか何とかちょっとした傾きがあるんです
その傾きのせいで出せる顔が似てしまうんですよ
例えば怒りっぽい人が大体怒りの顔は出し
たくさん出すんです 怒らなくてもいいのに怒った顔する
ちょっとしたことで笑う人だったら笑わなくてもいいのに
つまらないことなのにもう笑っちゃう
あるいはいつでも暗くて下向いてる人がいると
面白い話しているのに
別に面白い顔をしないで
何か鬱みたいな感じで下向いている
そういうことは人間の中によくあります
それはこの感情の微妙な傾きなんです
貪瞋痴 その傾きによって
あの ある一定の顔がたくさん出しちゃうんです
傾きない人はわけもわからないのをその場でその場で何か顔を見せる
それで傾き知っちゃうと我々は知ってます
あの人なら怒るでしょう
あ この人ならこれぐらいのことは気にしないでしょうという風に我々は言ったりする
それはその人の性格だと
これ 人間のこの性格だと俗世間で言っているのはこの感情の傾きなんです
俗世間で性格というものはこれなのです
しかし 教育環境によってはこの傾きが変わるのです
面白いことは では性格は一定している？それでもない
例えば教育によってこの傾きを変えることはできます
環境によっても変わっちゃう
例えば皆様はご飯を食べる時は結構計算しながら
あんまりたくさん食べてはいけないんだぞとかなんとかとかね
それで かなり豪華なホテルで豪華なブッフェやっているとすると
もう腹のところまで食べる
何なのかと 普段ずっとダイエットしているのに
野菜ばっかし食べてるのに
その時はデザートも食べるわ
ケーキも食べるわ もう何でも食べちゃう
いっぱい食べ物が並んでありますから
食べたい放題ということで
それ環境なんですよ こんな食べたらあかんぞと思ってる人なんですけど
ああいうちょっとした環境変わったところで性格が変わっていく
だから性格っていうのは環境によっても変わる
[咳]例えばいつ殺されるかわからない状態で
イラクやらパレスチナやらね
そういうところで生活している子供たちは
その環境によって変わっちゃうんですよ
鉄砲の音は聞いたことがない日本の子供なんかは
鉄砲の音を聞いちゃうと
あれ何？と言って走っていくかもしれません
そちらに なんか面白い音が聞いているんだから
行ってみ 行ってみましょうとかね
しかし 毎日自分の前で人が死んでいる場合は
その人々はもう音を聞いた途端もう隠れてしまうという性格になるんですね
だから そういう性格の傾きも
環境やら教育やら そういうものによっても変わります
で これから復題の再考管理どうしましょうかと
いわゆる性格の再考管理
今までの経験から現れてきた様々な性格を把握する
これはそのままで覚えるしかないんです
今皆さんは結構長い時間生きてきましたから
もうものすごいたくさん性格を持ったはずなんです
これはもう過去だからはっきり知ってるはずなんです
1枚1枚はわからないんだけど
大体大雑把ででもいいんだから
自分は子供頃どんな性格
それからどんな性格 それからどんな性格
仕事をする時どんな性格とかね
結婚する前に独身でいる時はどんな性格
結婚してからどんな性格
子供が産んでからどんな性格とかね
その場でそのたくさんありますから
いくらか把握してください
自分はどんな条件でどのような性格に変わるのかチェックしてください
次は 例えば買い物に行っちゃうと
結構厳密に品物を選んで物を買うかもしれませんし
時間制ありますね 時々 3時から 3時半までなんとかとかね
その時はもう 1,500円の品物は一人一つずつ 200円で売ったりとかね
普段は 1,500円なのに
そういうことも時々ある
このタイムセールですか
あれ？何て言いますか？タイムサービスとかね
そういうスーパーなんかはそういうことをやってます
そのタイムサービスにぶつかった時
自分がどんな性格とかとか
そうやってこの このチェックしてほしい
その条件に あの条件だったら私は怒ったと
この条件だったら怒らなかったとかチェックしてほしい
次に悪い結果 苦しみ 悩み
失敗を出す性格をマークする
これは全部過去のことなんですよ
だから あの場合は怒ってまずかったとかね
あの場合は優しく振り回ったところで大変な目に遭ったとかね
そういう失敗したことを悩むことになったもの
問題起こったこと 性格的にトラブったこととか
ちゃんとマーク入れておこう
同じ条件に再び出会っても
同じ顔を出さないように気をつける
それから 二度とやらんことにする
失敗は えーと まあそれで
もう 1枚あると思います
再考管理 自己管理できない人は感情で対応する
それで再考管理できない人は
その場でその場で感情でもう顔出すんですよ
いわゆる顔のセットで一番上の顔を出すんです
嫌な環境だったらすぐ怒る
相手がすごく美しい優しい人だったらニコッと笑ったりして
これやられますよ 時々この訪問販売やらセールスマンギャラね
すごい高価なネクタイつけて
かなり決まってるスーツを着て
すごく親切で行儀が良くて喋るんだから
奥さんたちやられます
だって見た目はすごく優しくてかっこいいんだから
いきなり欲の感情出すんです
だからこの自己管理できる人はそういうことはしません
一応マークって感情では対応しない
その時出した性格以外何も出せないと思っている
そこでセールスマンに騙されて 10万円のゴミを買わせたら
後で旦那さんが怒っちゃうと
そんなこと言ったってしょうがないんではないか
その人はすごく美しく
見事に品よく喋りましたからと言ったってダメはダメなんですけど
間違いは間違いなんですけど
だからだってしょうがないという言い訳なんですね
このだってしょうがないという言い訳は取り消しちゃうと人生から
もう完璧に生きていられます
そういう覚えやすいんですよ
絶対だってしょうがないっていう言い方はしないんだと
ではなくて いえ 私は計算して怒ったんだというふうに言えるならば
怒っても しかし 同じ条件で出せる顔がいくつもあるのです
だってしょうがないではないんですよ
いくつか顔あるんです
良い顔を選んで出しましょう
危険な顔が出る条件 環境を避けましょう
上手になるまではいくらか環境を避けた方がいいんです
怒る環境あったらちょっと避ける
金の無駄遣いする羽目になる友達のグループなんかあったら
そのコラボに行くことは半年間に一回ぐらいにする
毎週行かないで 行ったらみんな胸張ってお金使うんだから
自分もスイスイ胸張って無駄に使う可能性ありますからね
だからそういう環境を避ける
避けて悪いわけないんですよ
どうせ我々は変な社会に生きているんだから
それを避けたってどうしたことないんです
お釈迦様はとにかく悪い環境は極力避けてくださいと一般人に言ってるんです
人間っていうのは結構弱いんだからね
それで自分にいくつかの顔があるのかっていうテーマと
それでどうやってこの再考管理するのかっていう話はそこらで終了します
で 終わりとなります 何か質問等ありますか？ よろしいですか？ はい
英語とはのところでですね
実は全てが無常で流転していると
無常で流転っていうのはちょっとよくわからないんですが
あれはただいい加減に書いた言葉で
無常っていうのは変わるっていうことで
流転と言ったっても変わるというね
ぐるぐるぐるぐる変わっているもんだっていうね
そういうね でも今日覚えてほしいポイントは
我々は一回だけでも社会に出会わないということなんです
一人一人がある特定の社会に生きてるんです
それは普遍的な社会ではありません
これが全ての人間 それ一つ
それから生き方については
だってしょうがない生き方はしないぞと決めてもらえば
だってしょうがない しょうがないんじゃないかという文句は言わない生き方
出してみる 結構完璧に行くと思います
人生は で 質問があるならば出してください
ちょっともうちょっとその間でベラベラいろんなこと喋りますけど
なんでこんな話をそんなに言いますかというと
仏教っていうのはいろんな人々
いろんな人々をお釈迦様に会ったんですよ
会った会った人はお釈迦様は見事に育ててみせたんです
7歳の子供からもう90歳でももう100歳ぐらいの年取ってる人まで
もう年から見てもものすごい幅があるんです
お釈迦様は小さな子供に真理を教えてあげて
真理を悟らせてみせるんです
だからなんでそうできるのかというと
この性格っていうのはそんなもんなんです
変えられます 皆様知ってるアングリマーラというエピソードがありまして
殺人鬼なんたくさん人を殺しちゃったんですね
まあだってしょうがない
その人は殺すべき もう殺人鬼だから潰すべきとかね
そんな言葉をお釈迦様の単語にはない
そんな条件変えちゃえばね
あの人も立派な人間になるんだよと
で 条件変えてちゃんとした生き方を教えてあげて
悟った人間にしちゃったんです
完全に だからもうどんな人でも
もう知識 信じられないほど知識人
お釈迦様に会ったりしましたし
1行も勉強できない全く頭の悪い若者にも半日でというか
5000中で悟れるように教えたんです
だから仏教はそういう世界なんです
どんな人でも育ててみせる
だからこの罪に懺悔しなさい
そうすると神様は全部許してくれるんだぞというふうな軽々しい話はないんだ
ちょっと話はきついんです
お祈りすれば何でも解決するんだとかね
そういう風に全部まとめて一つで解決するということは仏教はしないんです
お腹が空いたらご飯食べなさい
病気になったら薬を飲みなさいという話であって
大丈夫大丈夫 お祈りすれば何でも叶いますよと言っちゃうと
お腹が空いてもお祈りすればいいし
病気になってもお祈りすればいいということになります
仕事がなければお祈りすればいいということになるんです
ブッダはそれにはものすごい断固反対なんです
その要求に応じて対応しなさいと
お腹が空いたらご飯食べる
病気になったら薬を飲みなさいと
お腹がお金がなかったら仕事をしなさいというような具体的な話なんです
それでお釈迦様は見事にいろんな人に
だから仏教経典というのは全部そういう話なんです
誰か誰かさんに会って
誰か誰かさんにこういうふうに質問されて
お釈迦様はこういうふうにこういうふうに答えたんだよとかね
そうやって この我々のこのごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃある複雑な性格をいかに完璧に丸くまとめて完成させたかという話は仏教の話なんです
そういうわけで こういうふうな説明にしたんです
だから こういうふうな見方
説明の仕方も 我々仏教の連中やってるんだったら
普通の世界ではあまりしないんです
皆さんは心理学の本とかお読みになったと思いますけど
その場合でも このパーソナリティの分析やら性格の分析やら性格の判断
いろいろあるでしょうね
でもアプローチがすごく違うんです
無常というアプローチは全くないんです
ということで 質問がございませんだったら
そこら辺で終了させていただきます
では 長い時間本当にどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます